(dramatic music playing)
Go ahead, just tell us.
♪
I killed her.
- Daniel Hegarty.
- June Lenker.
Thanks for seeing me.
♪
I'm investigating a phone call.
(phone ringing)
- dispatch: Police.
- woman: Listen, he's gonna kill me.
How can I help?
They made an allegation.
It was an old case that you worked.
woman: A long time ago,
my boyfriend, he stabbed her.
(busy signal)
You are aware that he confessed?
June: What if he's innocent?
♪
That case was investigated fairly.
(tense music playing)
- What is he hiding?
- Let it go.
Danny's one of the good ones.
♪
Daniel: There are things
that nobody teaches you.
Sometimes you have to go the extra mile.
There's no shame in that.
- We got our man.
- No, you got a confession.
- Daniel: We need to cover our backs.
- She's got it in for us.
June: I think he wants to fight.
I can do that.
That's the game. Collateral damage.
♪
Daniel: Do you know the difference
between order and chaos?
♪
Are you gonna stop me?
(screaming)
♪
Yeah.